ladies and gentlemen we have made it to
the final episode of kingdom least
season two no word on when season three
is coming out yep this has been
enjoyable right so far six by six one
more six and we got the devil's number
ladies and gentlemen if you hit that
like button that'd be very much
appreciated also subscribe and click
that notification bell to get notified
when our reaction for
all of us are dead or up in our time we
are actually shooting the finale first
that way we can get this out of the way
this zombie show so we can move on
comfortably to another south korean
zombie ship fresh palettes fresh ballad
right there full length watch along as
we sync up with the time code or over at
our patreon page major thanks to all
have become superjects by checking out
everything we got to offer over there
lastly the boys at prepper thank you so
much for helping us edit down the
highlights for all these episodes of
kingdom you guys do fantastic work let's
get to it
yes think of yourself for once
queen
[Laughter]
and mooyoung's baby
that's it that's my girl solving the
problems
burn it all
behind you
[Laughter]
the baby
come on sophie oh she better live
you got to be kidding me that baby's
amazing they discarded that baby
it's better than covering yourself in
zombie guts chills
that'll that'll keep them out
foreign
it's for all of us
[Applause]
ah
it's that funk base in there
[Laughter]
god always the palms always the palms
[Laughter]
that hurts even more when it's cold
told you not to look down
you're not yeah you're not gonna save
anybody there
come on man
yeah use that core
well the real-life dangers of running
these rooftops
zombie performers are really good at
using minimal arms
oh no
ugh
he's an incredible runner he's the tom
cruise of the series
[Applause]
some of that rage out prince
[Applause]
my god someone get him some fire
[Music]
oh cool nice use of tiles
dope thanks guys for showing up
come on you can figure out how to
reverse engineer this disease make the
cure
are you sure that baby wasn't bitten
does this break prick it's hard or is it
bit i can't tell
i don't think zombies would be able to
wrap it back up so maybe it's just
injured
oh smart
[Music]
smart
oh
you should have shot earlier started
[Laughter]
oh
nice
nice
oh
[Music]
what
no
oh you guys what
oh my god why are you using the front of
your fist just says this side
oh my god no
oh dude everyone's dead
no
queens guard oh my god everyone's gone
no
no
no what the [ __ ] no not young [ __ ] this
feels like a dream
this planet's going to [ __ ]
jump on it
nice good work
holy balls
couldn't the cold water stop some of the
lighting infection with the little
wormies coming back out
and also freeze them to death while
they're under there
take care of two birds with one stone
get them worms out
coming out of his eyes
everyone's fine
yeah if this guy's fine
i don't think they were informed about
the cold water were they
not except maybe the didn't she show the
price shark zombies yes
they swim now
we should kill each other just to be
safe
who wants to go first
wow what a cool image
m
[Laughter]
what
[Music]
um
[Music]
the baby's all grown up that's exactly
what i was gonna say
damn three months later they're still
getting rid of bodies
what
very mature kids seven years old
i guess so
where's chang hiding is he a fisherman
now is he gonna give the lecture
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
there's so many
holes in what you just said nothing
would be here without you
this decision is being made way too on
the spot
legacy is not an honor then who young
gets forgotten
it's not like you just beheaded your
father everyone knows he's a sub it's
probably just with his uncle fishing
in
um
[Laughter]
they made their life school let's just
get rid of these plants huh
now no one will recognize them
um
[Music]
or they're just hiding underneath the
floorboards
oh my god they're gonna come up from the
water
no
no
what is happening
kill the king
i don't know what to do
oh my god it's going to wait till he's a
grown mountain it's his brain's fully
developed
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
no
oh so it is waiting until those brains
fully develop
no
ah
[Music]
well that sucks
after seven years
[ __ ] seven years of tranquility
i assume
this symbolic rebirth
if so
it's a special number i know who that
woman was oh
me too yup yup
then if you guys don't you're stupid
you're all dumb and you should be able
to guess you're all dumb you need
everything spoon fed to you i had a
while to figure out who it would be
no no idea who that is no idea
i guess it makes sense that you see
prince you [ __ ] up man
you didn't think long term enough think
what would happen a few years down the
road yeah
see you bye
seo buy yes search engine optimization
buy she
failed us all that figuring out
mvp status revoked she said brain not
fully developed but i guess i thought
she got rid of it i thought she did but
one of those worms must have just been
like nah man i know whose body this is
and this is too important can we just
dip that kid in cold water again it
would seem like you could the kid must
never have baths or they must always be
warm
[Laughter]
she's never been in cold water before
yeah i guess not
or that worm is just really sticking it
out maybe the worms have evolved
i mean the bike mark doesn't look like
it healed at all yeah it looks pretty
mangled and nasty it looks worse than it
did when it was just a bite mark yeah
it's just grown and no one's been like
hey man that birthmark
a little bit especially when everyone
knows where it comes from after seven
years that ain't looking so good yeah
damn that sucks
there's a good finale though yeah i
forgot in the moment about until they
hit the water that like oh yeah they
could freeze that [ __ ] out yeah i was
like i guess we're just ending this show
right now i guess everyone would love it
he's gonna die
i think we're just done but no i thought
the way they compose that finale i
especially admire the rooftop chase
because that's such a realistic version
of a rooftop chase on that kind of
roof tile yeah whatever that's i don't
know what kind of tyler that's called
like terra cotta tiles i don't know if
you a lot of those shingles or not but a
lot of those in uh los angeles i mean on
that on the roofs yeah out here love
those and um
yeah so when you run on them and like
they always do that in action movies and
stuff they run on those but i liked how
here they just kept slipping and falling
to the ground and yeah getting caught up
in the horde it's like those must not be
as stuck down as they look in every tom
cruise movie yeah yeah
and and when they are running uh on the
ice i thought that was a really
beautiful sequence as well
when uh they're they're trying to break
it i like the realism of that too of
they should just start shooting that ice
yeah just immediately just immediately
looking like a warm up they're gonna
come for you anyway they're already
coming for you just warm up making some
noise you know yeah like getting getting
started create a perimeter start firing
yeah smashing those butts into the ice
that way you're ready to go yeah because
yeah that was uh that was a really well
really well visually realized sequence
and i thought yeah i thought that was
really cool they did a lot of setting up
in the last half here though yes i guess
it's like a two two part episode here
yeah yeah they do a lot i mean the rap
i'm glad the queen finally got bit
she got turned it was gratifying that
was gratifying yeah especially because
it goes down like i like that there's no
she's not too
like
evil villainy where it's just like yeah
now she's just gonna die right here on
the throne
oh yeah she knows what she got into and
uh she's going out this way
i guess uh i didn't fully
i guess after watching this whole
journey of prince chang i wasn't
a hundred percent on board with his
decision at the end
just say you don't want to kill a baby
just say you don't want to kill a baby
guy
that's really what it was
listen guys i know you're right however
this is my best friend's kid yeah i
can't just say i don't want to kill the
kid yeah
like i get it you don't want to murder a
baby i i completely understand they
could have just sent the baby off to to
live its life someplace else just give
the baby to someone else yeah i said
like you raised this baby yeah give it
back to muyong's wife so is this baby
gonna remember anything yeah
what's going on oh yeah where is
muyong's wife she alive still i think we
saw one one shot of her here at one
point okay yeah
was she one of the people watching i
think she was dropping she was like
eavesdropper yeah yeah she was
eavesdropping pretty sure that was her
oh poorly i was like what sun grow into
the freaking principle yeah what weird
terrible life is she gonna lead now no
special privileges either i know
because nobody can know
uh yeah i mean that was that was
fascinating but
know he's like saying
i i beheaded my reputation ahead of my
dad well everyone knows why you did it
now yeah and uh
you know guilty of treason but you were
right
everyone know the whole point is you're
right about yeah and even if there's
still heinous supporters out there i
feel like you've had enough
i don't know i mean maybe there's way
way more people than this show hints at
out there you know to to wrangle in the
kingdom but it seems like you've had
enough high ranking people from across
the array of you know moving parts to
keep this kingdom running see the truth
yeah that you might be able to
orchestrate a different lie although see
i'm torn because part of me feels like
yeah there is a certain
element of like it it it could have been
a little more like
solidly climactic with prince chang or
something it's like i appreciate the
decision from the character because i'm
like yeah he's just not gonna kill you
know he's not going to kill muy young's
son but at the same time
uh
yeah i'm i'm a little torn and i'm
curious as to where i'm going to land on
that because part of me is like yeah it
makes sense to me like you're not really
you're a good
leader you're a good you know crown
prince potential king
but you know i mean this is gonna be
what your life is about now yeah you
know you're not gonna go back and do
ceremonial [ __ ] and hang out on the
throne and you know like
so you but him being there does pose a
threat because the the clans would still
be like yeah [ __ ] that prince chain guy
yeah yeah it's like if he returns too
there's there yeah there could be more
mutiny or there could be people who
would be like i don't care i don't care
what happened yeah the war would wage
especially because the queen's now dead
too yeah
so
even though they wouldn't it's like just
talk it out it's like god damn
conversation
it's not our fault the zombie infection
happened killed everyone here yeah
a bunch of [ __ ]
i mean could he still hang out there and
just let i feel like the baby prince
take over couldn't he like
could he denounce it or no
that's an excellent question i don't
know how the rules work and i don't know
either
i don't think you can denounce it
because part of me feels like there
would still be some kind of i don't know
if you're gonna go that far you can't
really split the difference and then
have people be like well you know the
treason
and you're here and you're recognizing
this king's legitimacy now but also you
know you don't want us to charge you for
the treason so i i i feel like it would
lead to more
sort of troubles although i mean at the
same time it doesn't seem like
impossible for him to return to some
kind of advisor instead
that's true but i don't know i i thought
as a gesture the whole thing of like
okay you know we'll just have it be that
you know nobody really knows the actual
truth the king and the queen perished in
the war and so did i and you know now
things can begin anew and it's like i i
appreciate that i see what he's trying
to do there
and i think dramatically speaking it's
nice because it is like okay it gives
you that false sense of we actually did
finish this scenario
and now i want to rest
he's not resting no he's not he's spent
the last seven years committing his life
to
uncovering more of these plants becoming
a badass zombie plant hunter yeah
who is this woman i don't understand
what her deal is i don't know she's
either i mean she's either a villain or
an unlikely ally i think she's the one
selling [ __ ]
right
it's a good solid guess
she i don't think that smile on her face
means
thank god you've arrived
it looks like she has
some type of like messed up plan up her
sleeve yeah i can absolutely imagine
that that seems like what they're
setting up i mean okay is there anyone
oh [ __ ] if that that freaking king is is
going to be a zombie now
if they could start the play although
it's backed it's like what are they
going to do in the next one okay
here hear me out prince chang returns
then he hears the king's gone all
zombified
he comes back he's like guys
i'm back from the dead but in a clearly
better way
than the current king is
let me take care of it okay
and then he'll you know pretend to be
some kind of you know
resurrected
what is the shin of the north it's the
netflix movie of kingdom and who is a
shin
i have a sneaky suspicion of shin is
probably that woman oh really maybe like
they said they got it from somebody in
the north and you know people in the
comments have been sounding off about
the movie and so i was thinking maybe
maybe that
it's gotta be so we don't know who
[Music]
shin is probably her right that would be
my guess yeah
okay yeah so i want you to watch a whole
movie that's right it's just like the
witcher
in between
we're gonna hit you with a movie or an
anime or something
supplementary material
oh man i wouldn't be able to get around
to that for a while the whole movie yeah
whole motion picture is three hours long
and how long is it it's probably like an
hour i'm gonna say an hour and 25
minutes
an hour and 30.
take some time to squeeze that into the
middle of this sketches
okay well eventually maybe we'll wait
till kingdom season three that's you
never watch it yeah so
it's a good one yeah yeah well yeah
getting back into it right before season
three yeah yeah yeah
check out the movie get a little primer
on who our new character might be blind
people we watch this show
yeah absolutely and then we'll have yeah
a nice little thing to anticipate
um there we go there's our excuse good
watch the time we post this kingdom
season three surprise announcements
dropping early
all 19 episodes
um yeah damn that was uh that was wild
uh yeah it was very like a very
straightforward but very graceful and
very you know intense finale i would say
and some nice moments of levity
i guess the shin's not a bad guy
i don't know
i honestly don't know i feel like it
could go either way maybe it's neither
maybe a shin is is a you know gray area
character
yeah
well [ __ ]
i mean
what they didn't really set up was
political [ __ ]
yeah i'm like is it just another zombie
i mean it's the show's obviously at it's
big best when it's the zombie stuff but
i think the political stuff needs to
complement it you do they need to be
just as ingrained as each other yeah
because i'm like okay are you just
setting up another like infection around
the world
yeah and now we're going to be taking
them on
or
you know how will this play in political
wise
is there going to be some element where
like there's the
it's detail throughout this season that
you know there's the war with japan are
we going to do something with china next
season because they brought that up at
the end china
huge outbreak the biggest outbreak
we have the best tracks direction plans
uh yeah that's a good question because i
mean my mind starts going okay so you're
you have yeah like the sort of
similar but inverted situation with the
king which will throw things into
disarray of just like a general variety
and then there's the potential for like
okay so prince chang is probably gonna
have to re-emerge
in some fashion
which will cause yeah because the
[ __ ] king is gonna be a zombie now he
is like i'm back to take my throne i
never wanted to leave listen guys i made
up this thing in the history and
actually that was a mistake i'm your
leader you trust me right the guy who
lied
away for seven years i thought this
could work out but uh it turns out it's
not working out so i'm back and uh hey
i'm the right flair to the throne turns
out just one zombie bike can screw that
entire kingdom up i know the scary thing
about zombies
one bite spreads
they should at least be informed about
the cold water trick i know everyone
should be informed about the cold water
trick it's funny i feel like yeah
there should be just like should be
guidelines in case this happens dump
your body in ice cold water there should
be like what do you call helpful
propaganda like just big posters around
of like hey if you see somebody you know
with blood running down their face who's
just snapping at you hey try and get
them into some ice water
if you see a zombie say something
if they're already turned that means
they're dead already
yeah it has to be that the realism
it has to be no [ __ ] before they die
yeah before they transform because what
happens is
do you not know the rules i'm sorry
they're bit they slowly die and then
when they're dead the worm goes into the
brain and takes over the body
so what you're watching is a giant worm
is a worm controlling a body yes so you
know you just you got time until they
die yes it's true it's true
um damn
all right well those are smart ass worms
they are very intelligent
that way and then the body compensates
for the rest
hungry everybody compensates for the
rest that's smart they know exactly what
each part of the brain does yeah
they're experts they have their own
little manuals
all right all right guys well kingdom
good finale i might prefer the
penultimate one just a little bit more
but uh i still thought this was really
this is really solid family it's much
better than last season's finale
where they they went hey wait let's make
this two seasons even though it's not
yeah yeah i was told the show was about
to end i was too i really was like oh
damn is this just two and done or one
and done right yeah
but uh yeah it's good [ __ ] you get some
reinvention next season all right guys
well keep a lookout for whenever we come
to recover kingdom of the north
a shin of the north i mean
we don't know when kingdom season three
is coming right they even filmed it
i have no idea netflix has not renewed
or canceled kingdom for a third season
yet
hmm
i
mean it's gotta be
you can't just end it like that
and netflix will do that
they will
unfortunately
i don't know it seems like it would be
uh it seems like it would be renewed
yeah
is i think it's a hit
oh [ __ ] of the north is set before the
first season even
prequel
prequel time
uh it must be where like really came
from then yeah true origins
yeah they released the [ __ ] in the north
on july 23rd 2021 so so it's not been
that long even yeah
a second special episode on the crown
prince is reported to be in the works
scheduled for release in 2023.
there's a weird franchise
so we're gonna do
your third season for yeah
yeah we're gonna make a couple
special episodes which are actually just
movies yes
and then uh we'll go back to making
episodes of varying lengths in the
actual season set this up for a third
season just focus on that don't do that
that's ridiculous nah man it's netflix
we can't just do
regular one show with seasons we gotta
have a universe
all right guys well thank you so much
for being here we'll see you guys soon
[Music]
you